Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The natives, who had assembled to oppose the landing of our soldiers, and were standing either on dry land or else a short distance out into the sea, fought with all their limbs unencumbered and on familiar ground, boldly hurling javelins and galloping their horses, who were trained to this kind of work. These perils frightened our soldiers, who were quite unaccustomed to battles of this kind,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当地土著聚集在一起抵抗我们士兵的登陆，他们有的站在干地上，有的站在离海不远浅水处，四肢行动毫无束缚，又在熟悉的地形上，大胆地投掷标枪，骑着专门训练过这种战事的马匹奔驰。这些险情吓坏了我们的士兵，他们对这种战斗完全不习惯，
with the result that they did not show the same alacrity and enthusiasm as they usually did in battles on dry land. But as the Romans still hesitated, chiefly on account of the depth of water, the man who carried the eagle of the tenth legion, after praying to the gods that his action might bring good luck to the legion, cried in a loud voice, Jump down, comrades, unless you want to surrender our eagle to the enemy, I at any rate mean to do my duty to my country and my general. With those words he leapt out of the ship and advanced towards the
因此他们表现出的机敏和热情不如以往在陆地上作战时那样高涨。但正当罗马人还在犹豫时——主要是因为水深——第十军团的鹰旗手在向诸神祈祷、祈求他的行动能给军团带来好运之后，大声喊道：“士兵们，跳下去吧，除非你们想把我们的鹰旗交给敌人；反正我，是要对我的国家和我的统帅尽到职责了。”说罢，他便跳出船去，
enemy with the eagle in his hands. At this, the soldiers, exhorting each other not to submit to such a disgrace, jumped with one accord from the ship, and the men from the next ships, when they saw them, followed them and advanced against the enemy. So that, Tom, was Julius Caesar's account of the Gallic War, as read some years later by General Maximus from Gladiator. I thought you were going to say Nick Cave, my new celebrity listener. Yeah. Or, I don't know, David Boone or some other Australian. What other Australians do you know, Tom? I know so many Australians, but we haven't got time because we've got to talk about Julius Caesar.
手里拿着鹰旗向敌人冲去。士兵们见状，互相勉励，不甘心遭受这样的耻辱，便齐刷刷地从船上跳了下去；后面船上的人看到他们，也跟着跳下来，向敌人发起了进攻。所以，汤姆，那是尤利乌斯·恺撒对高卢战争的记述，几年后由《角斗士》中的马克西穆斯将军朗读出来。我还以为你要说是尼克·凯夫呢，我的新名人听众。是啊。或者，我不知道，大卫·布恩或其他什么澳大利亚人。你还知道什么澳大利亚人，汤姆？我知道的澳大利亚人可多了，但我们没时间了，因为我们得聊聊尤利乌斯·恺撒。
Anyway, this was Russell Crowe. I did because we've got to talk about Julius Caesar. Anyway, this was Russell Crowe. I did it as Russell Crowe, as Julius Caesar. I know, but Russell Crowe's New Zealand, isn't he? Well, he's a bit of both, isn't he? Yeah, I know. I did it as that because I wanted to capture the sort of martial vigour and the excitement of this moment. So this is the moment in 55 BC that the Romans land on... Are you going to be doing this throughout the four episodes?
总之，这是罗素·克劳。我刚才就是这么做的，因为我们得聊聊尤利乌斯·恺撒。总之，这就是罗素·克劳。我是以罗素·克劳的方式演的。我知道，但罗素·克劳是新西兰人，对吧？嗯，他有点两边都沾，不是吗？对，我知道。我这么模仿是因为我想捕捉那种尚武的活力和这一时刻的兴奋感。所以这是公元前 55 年，罗马人登陆……你在这四集节目里都要这么演吗？
I think I'll do it unexpectedly, when listeners are least expecting it. When the Romans land on British soil. So, Tom, the exciting thing for me about this, I can remember when I was 13 doing a big kind of timeline of British history, and this was the very first date. It's the first date really in all history, isn't it? 55 BC. It's the first date in British history, obviously. And so there's a famous joke about this in 1066 and all that. It was written in 1930 that makes a joke about the state of historical knowledge
我想我会出其不意地来这么一下，就在听众最意想不到的时候。当罗马人登陆英国本土时。所以，汤姆，对我来说，这件事最令人兴奋的是，我还记得我13岁时做过一份英国历史的大事年表，而这就是最早的一个日期。这可以说是所有历史中的第一个日期，不是吗？公元前55年。显然，这是英国历史上的第一个日期。关于这一点，在《1066年及所有那类事情》中有一个著名的笑话。这本书写于1930年，它拿英国人的历史知识状况开了一个玩笑
in Britain. And it has 1066 and all that. That's obviously one date, 1066. But the only other date in the entire book is this date, 55 BC. So he says the first date in English history is 55 BC. Oh God, I'm starting to do a New Zealand accent there. In which year, Julius Caesar, the memorable Roman emperor, landed like all other successful invaders of these islands at Thanet. This was in the olden days when the Romans were top nation on account of their classical education, et cetera. And obviously that's a joke that depends on people reading this being able to think that Britain is still top nation due to its classical education. It highlights the way in which maybe
在英国。书里确实提到了1066和所有那类事情。那显然是一个日期，1066年。但整本书里仅有的另一个日期就是这个日期，公元前55年。所以他说英国历史上的第一个日期是公元前55年。哦天哪，我开始在那儿学新西兰口音了。在哪一年，尤利乌斯·恺撒这位著名的罗马皇帝，像这些岛屿所有其他成功的侵略者一样，在萨尼特登陆了。这是在古代，当时罗马人凭借他们的古典教育等等，是头号大国。显然，这个笑话的前提是，读到这里的人会认为英国由于其古典教育仍然是头号大国。它突显了一种方式，也许
in 1930, attitudes to empire and the pacification of natives were slightly different because it goes on to make the joke, the Roman conquest was a good thing since the Britons were only natives at the time. That question of whether the Roman conquest was a good thing since the Britons were only natives at the time. And so that question of whether the Roman conquest was a good thing or a bad thing. I mean, when I was growing up as a child, I'm sure you read the Lady Bird book about Julius Caesar and the conquest of Britain. I think it was generally held to be a good thing. It kind of introduced hot baths, wines, straight roads, all that kind of thing. The end of the use of woad and people no longer being blue. I think hair is an important element of this.
在1930年，人们对帝国和安抚土著的态度略有不同，因为接下来它开玩笑说：“罗马的征服是一件好事，因为当时不列颠人不过是些土著。”关于罗马人的征服究竟是一件好事，因为当时不列颠人只是土著。因此，关于罗马人的征服是一件好事还是一坏事的问题。我的意思是，当我还是个孩子的时候，我确信你读过关于尤利乌斯·恺撒和征服不列颠的瓢虫书。我认为人们普遍认为这是一件好事。它算是引入了热水浴、葡萄酒、笔直的道路诸如此类的东西。结束了对菘蓝的使用，人们不再浑身涂得蓝蓝的。我认为头发是其中一个重要元素。
We will be coming to that, yes. I think a sense in which the haircut arrived in 55 BC, subsequently when Claudius came in the second invasion. I think there's that element to it. But also, of course, the wider point is the story is always told from the perspective of the Romans. So the people travelling and the people who land, hence the introduction. But also, do you not think the ancient Britons were not really seen by imperial kind of British writers and readers in the 19th and 20th century as the desired
我们马上会谈到这一点，是的。我认为发型是在公元前55年随之而来的，后来克劳狄乌斯在第二次入侵时也是如此。我认为其中有这样一个因素。但当然，更广泛的观点是，这个故事总是从罗马人的角度来讲述的。因此是旅行的人和登陆的人，这就是引言的由来。但你难道不认为，在19和20世纪，古代不列颠人并没有真正被帝国的英国作家和读者视为理想的
ancestor? The desired ancestor was to some degree the Anglo-Saxons and the heritage is that of Rome. So we identify more with the Romans in that story, don't we? As readers, we're expected to identify with the Romans. I think educated people in the era when the British Empire existed were much more inclined to side with the Romans. But I think there was a kind of trend to identify with the Britons as well. So you think of the statue of Boudicca, or Boadicea as she was then called, that stands outside the Houses of Parliament and will be coming to Boudicca later
祖先吗？理想的祖先在某种程度上是盎格鲁-撒克逊人，而我们的文化遗产属于罗马。所以在这个故事中，我们更多地与罗马人产生共情，不是吗？作为读者，我们被期望与罗马人产生共情。我认为在存在大英帝国的那个时代，受过教育的人更倾向于站在罗马人一边。但我认为，当时也存在一种与不列颠人产生共情的倾向。所以你会想到布狄卡（当时被称为博阿迪西亚）的雕像，它就矗立在议会大厦外面，我们在这部系列的后面也会讲到布狄卡。
in this series. I mean, she is a British heroine, despite the fact that she actually burnt down London. So I think there's always been an ambivalence and I think that that ambivalence has become stronger over recent decades for obvious reasons, much greater scepticism about empire and a kind of an awareness of the costs of empire. But I think that actually it's completely non-debate because, of course, both sides are unfathomably alien, unfathomably distant from us. One of the things that when I was just mapping out the course of these four episodes we're going to be doing on the Roman conquest of Britain that struck me was how often I was picking up echoes of other episodes that we've done. So whether
我的意思是，尽管她实际上烧毁了伦敦，但她依然是一位英国女英雄。所以我认为一直存在着一种矛盾心理，而且我认为这种矛盾心理在最近几十年变得更加强烈，原因显而易见，那就是对帝国的怀疑大大增加，并且对帝国的代价有了某种认识。但我认为，实际上这完全是一个不用争论的问题，因为当然，双方都深不可测地异质、与我们深不可测地疏远。当我刚刚规划我们要做的关于罗马征服不列颠的这四集节目的走向时，让我震惊的一件事是，我经常能听到我们过去做过的其他节目的回响。所以无论是
the conquest of the Aztecs or the series we did on Custer and the Plains Indians, there are echoes there, but I'm always aware that they might be delusory and deceptive. I think one of the things for us and for everyone listening to bear in mind is firstly, that the evidence we have for this entire story is very patchy. And the consequence of that is that there's so much about both sides that we can't know. But I do think that you're right to say that it is easier for us, I think, to identify with the Romans simply because the written sources that we have for this story comes from them. You described Caesar, so he's approaching in his ships and jumping into the sea and crambling up onto the beach. This is our country, but we're kind of with
征服阿兹特克人，还是我们制作的关于卡斯特和平原印第安人的系列节目，其中都有回响，但我一直清醒地认识到，它们可能是虚幻和具有欺骗性的。我认为对于我们和所有收听节目的每个人来说，需要记住的一点是，首先，我们掌握的关于这个完整故事的证据非常零碎。其结果就是，双方都有太多我们无法了解的情况。但我确实认为你是对的，我们更容易与罗马人产生共情，这主要是因为我们关于这个故事的书面资料都来自于他们。你形容恺撒，他乘船接近，跳进海里，挣扎着爬上海滩。这是我们的国家，但我们在某种程度上是和
Caesar's legions in the boats because we don't know really very much about Britain, say relative to what we know about Rome. Right. But also people identify with the Romans from actually quite a small age, a young age, don't they? You often do the Romans at school when you're, what, five, six, seven. We know a lot about the lives of the Romans. We know a lot about the life of Julius Caesar. We can make educated guesses about his inner life, about his psychology, about what kind of a man he was. We can't do anything like that with any single person really who lived on the island of Great
小船里的恺撒军团在一起的，因为相对于我们对罗马的了解，我们对不列颠其实知之甚少。没错。但人们对罗马人的共情也是从很小的年龄、很小的时候就开始了，不是吗？你通常在学校里学罗马历史，大概是什么时候，五岁、六岁、七岁。我们对罗马人的生活了解很多。我们对尤利乌斯·恺撒的生活了解很多。我们可以对他的内心生活、他的心理、他是一个什么样的人做出有根据的猜测。而在历史上的这个时期，生活在大不列颠岛上的任何一个人，我们都无法做到这一点。我们所知道的只有名字。
Britain at this point in history. All we know is the name. And so I think that because our written sources come from the Romans, but for them, the Greeks as well, there's a sense in which we're looking at this story, we have a sense of Britain slowly coming into focus that is one that derives from those sources. So if you go right back to the beginning, to the earliest written texts, possibly alluding to Britain, they're Greek, not Roman. So you have Herodotus, the first great historian. He doubts Britain even exists. He says, you know, that there are said to be islands out there, but I don't believe it. He has a contemporary who's a geographer called Hecateus. He mentioned there being an island beyond Gaul that he called Hyperborea. He says that it's sacred to Apollo, the god of the sun,
所以我想，由于我们的书面资料来自罗马人，当然对他们来说也来自希腊人，某种程度上我们是在观察这个故事，我们有一种不列颠慢慢进入人们视线的印象，而这种印象正是源于那些资料。所以如果你一直追溯到最初，追溯到那些可能暗示不列颠的最早书面文本，它们是希腊的，而不是罗马的。所以你有希罗多德，第一位伟大的历史学家。他甚至怀疑不列颠是否存在。他说，你知道，据说海外有岛屿，但我才不信呢。他有一个同时代的同行，是一位名叫赫卡泰奥斯的地理学家。他提到在高卢之外有一个岛屿，他称之为“极北之地”（Hyperborea）。他说它是献给太阳神阿波罗的圣地，
and that it boasts a temple that is spherical in shape. People have thought maybe that's a reference to Stonehenge. I doubt it, but I quite like the idea for obvious reasons. And then after them, we do start to get slightly more secure references to Britain. And this is due to a Greek who sails from Massilia, which is the Greek foundation that today is Marseille. And he sailed to Britain and to this mysterious island called Ultima Thule. Unclear exactly where it is, but probably, I think, Iceland. He describes it as being six days voyage beyond Britain. And it's close to where the sea becomes impenetrable because it's kind of becoming solid, which
并且拥有一座呈球形的宏伟神庙。人们认为这可能是指巨石阵。我对此表示怀疑，但出于显而易见的原因，我挺喜欢这个想法的。在此之后，我们确实开始得到关于不列颠的更确凿的记载。这要归功于一位从马西利亚（即今天的马赛这个希腊殖民地）起航的希腊人。他航行到了不列颠以及这个名为“ ultima thule”（极北之岛）的神秘岛屿。具体在哪里并不清楚，但我认为很可能是冰岛。他将其描述为从不列颠出发航行六天的路程。它靠近大海变得无法航行的地方，因为海水正在变得坚硬，这
must be a reference to kind of, you know, ice, pack ice or whatever. So Iceland seems to be the likeliest candidate. And it has to be said that he is much quoted, but also much despised. Lots of the claims that he's making are seen as being so outlandish that people discount it. But I think that we can see that he did go there from what he says. So in his book on the ocean, which hasn't survived, but is quoted a lot, he refers to Britain, to Ireland, to all the other various islands in our archipelago as being a single island, the Nessos Praetaniki, so the British island. The idea of them being British Isles is not something that doesn't originate with the
一定是指某种冰，比如浮冰之类的东西。所以冰岛似乎是最有可能的候选地。必须承认，他被大量引用，但也备受鄙视。他所做的许多主张被视为如此离奇，以至于人们对其不屑一顾。但我认为，从他的言论中可以看出他确实去过那里。因此，在他的著作《论大洋》（该书未能流传下来，但被大量引用）中，他将不列颠、爱尔兰以及我们群岛中的所有其他各个岛屿统称为一个单一的岛屿，即 Nessos Praetaniki，也就是不列颠岛。将它们视为不列颠群岛的概念，并不是什么
British Empire or anything like that. That's the foundational description. Tom, I'm so pleased to hear this. It's P, not B. It's's the Pretani rather than the Britani. And in Welsh, Britain is still, I think, called Priddon to this day. So there's a kind of a trace element of that. The name probably means the painted ones. So in Latin, the Picti, the Picts, referring to the fondness for tattoos. And Pythias also seems to have given individual names to the two largest islands. So Albion to Great Britain, Ierne is Ireland,
大英帝国或类似的东西所发源的概念。那是基础性的描述。汤姆，听到这个我太高兴了。是 P，而不是 B。那是普雷塔尼人（Pretani），而不是不列颠人（Britani）。在威尔士语中，直到今天不列颠似乎仍然被称为 Priddon。所以这里面有一种痕迹元素。这个名字的意思可能就是“画了彩绘的人”。所以在拉丁语中，Picti，即皮克特人，指的就是他们对纹身的喜爱。皮西亚斯似乎也给这两个最大的岛屿起了各自的名字。大不列颠被称为阿尔比恩（Albion），爱尔兰被称为伊尔内（Ierne），
and he refers to two promontories in the south. So the westernmost promontory, which is today called Cornwall, is called Beleriand, which is very Tolkien, isn't it? And the eastern one is called Cantian, so that's Kent. And Kent and Thames, the river, are the two oldest attested place names in Britain, and Pythias mentions both of them. And so this is in, what, 320 BC, so a long, long time ago. But because so many of the scholars and geographers and historians who follow Pythias, although they use him, they dismiss him as a fabulist and a fantasist, there is this sense that continues right the way up into the lifetime of Julius Caesar in the first century BC, that Britain is a land of mystery, that people don't really know anything
他还提到了南部的两个岬角。所以最西边的岬角，也就是今天的康沃尔，被称为贝勒里安德（Beleriand），这非常托尔金，不是吗？东边的岬角被称为坎蒂安（Cantian），也就是肯特。肯特和泰晤士河是不列颠境内仅有的两个历史最悠久的 attested 地名，皮西亚斯都提到了它们。这大约是在公元前320年，是很久很久以前的事了。但由于许多跟随皮西亚斯的学者、地理学家和历史学家，尽管他们使用了他的资料，却把他贬低为爱编造故事的骗子和幻想家，这就造成了一种观念，一直持续到公元前1世纪尤利乌斯·恺撒的有生之年：不列颠是一片神秘的土地，人们对它一无所知
about it. And I think that for Caesar, that's precisely the appeal. That's precisely why he's going there, is that it is a place of such fantasy and mystery that to be the Roman who lands there first is an absolute kind of massive great tick against his name. So let's put Caesar into some context. We've talked about him in previous episodes of The Rest is History. You've written about him a lot. He is very charismatic, charming. He is incredibly ambitious from a very well-heeled family. Yeah, but a family that hasn't really measured up to the standards of its ancestry. So Caesar undoubtedly feels that as a burden. And also he's surrounded by other big beasts in the Roman
关于它的一切。我认为对恺撒来说，这恰恰是它的吸引力所在。这正是他要去那里的原因，因为它是一个充满幻想和神秘的地方，能够成为第一个登陆那里的罗马人，对他来说绝对是一个巨大的成就。因此，让我们把恺撒置于某种背景中来看待。我们在《历史的余烬》之前的节目中谈论过他。你写过很多关于他的文章。他极具个人魅力，富有魔力。他出身名门，有着极其远大的抱负。是的，但这个家族并没有真正达到其祖先的标准。所以恺撒毫无疑问地感受到了这种负担。而且他周围都是罗马
political scene, say Pompey or Crassus, who have done great things, and Caesar wants a bit of it. And I think that in terms of understanding why he goes to Britain, there's a story that Suetonius, his biographer, reports about 180 odd years later, but clearly has an element of truth, that he's a magistrate serving in Spain. And he goes to Gardes, which is Cadiz. And in the temple there, he sees a statue of Alexander the Great. And when he sees it, Suetonius says he groaned as though in disgust at his own lack of accomplishment, because at an age when Alexander had already conquered the world, he himself had achieved nothing memorable. And then the following night, he's supposed to have had a terrible dream in which he forces
政治舞台上的其他巨兽，比如庞培或克拉苏，他们都建立过伟大的功业，而恺撒也想分一杯羹。我认为，要理解他为什么要去不列颠，有一个由他的传记作家苏埃托尼乌斯在180多年后记载的故事，但显然包含着事实的要素：当时他在西班牙担任地方官。他去了加迪斯（Gades）。在那里的一座神庙里，他看到了一尊亚历山大大帝的雕像。看到它时，苏埃托尼乌斯说他发出了呻吟，仿佛在厌恶自己缺乏成就，因为在亚历山大已经征服世界的年纪里，他自己却一事无成。而在接下来的那天晚上，据说他做了一个可怕的梦，在梦中他强迫
himself on his mother, which is very, obviously, I mean, a horribly unsettling dream. Dr. Freud would be all over that. But then it's explained to him, and I quote Suetonius, that his mother, whom he had seen powerless to push him aside as he raped her, was none other than the earth, held to be the parent of all, and that his dream was therefore prophecy that he would rule the world. And so there's this idea, I think, that by reaching out to seize control of distant lands. So first of all, Gaul, Caesar ends up governor of Gaul, and he pacifies that over the course of the early years of his term of governorship, very bloodily. And then he's kind of looking ahead to other places. So I think the ocean is on his mind because one of the peoples in Gaul that he subdues is a people in Brittany or Amorica
他的母亲与他发生关系，这显然——我的意思是，这是一个极其令人不安的梦。弗洛伊德博士会对这个大加分析。但后来有人向他解释——我引用苏埃托尼乌斯的话——他看到的那个在他施暴时无力将他推开的母亲，不是别人，正是被视为万物之母的大地，因此他的梦是一个预言，预示他将统治世界。所以我想，这里有一种想法，那就是通过向外抓取、夺取对遥远土地的控制权。首先是高卢，恺撒最终成为了高卢总督，在他的总督任期初年，他极其血腥地平定了高卢。然后他开始放眼其他地方。所以我想大洋一直占据着他的脑海，因为他在高卢制服的一个部族，居住在布列塔尼或阿莫里卡
as it was called, called the Veneti, the Venetians, confusingly. And they're a naval power and they impose tolls on merchants who want to cross the channel and trade with Britain. And Caesar commissions a fleet, which he entrusts to Decimus Brutus, one of his lieutenants, who will end up being one of his assassins. Decimus Brutus defeats the Venetian fleet. Meanwhile, Caesar has gone along the rocky coastline of Brittany, Amorica, subduing the Venetians there. He describes the Venetians on Amorica, on Brittany, as being surrounded by the great unbounded ocean. And now that Caesar has this fleet, which he's used to defeat them, he must be thinking,
（当时对该地区的称呼），名叫韦内蒂人（Veneti），令人困惑的是，他们也被称为威尼斯人。他们是一支海军力量，对想要穿过海峡与不列颠进行贸易的商人征收通行费。恺撒委托建造了一支舰队，并将其交给了他的副将之一德西穆斯·布鲁图斯，此人最终将成为他的刺客之一。德西穆斯·布鲁图斯击败了韦内蒂舰队。与此同时，恺撒沿着布列塔尼和阿莫里卡多岩石的海岸线前进，征服了那里的韦内蒂人。他将阿莫里カ和布列塔尼的韦内蒂人描述为被浩瀚无垠的大洋所包围。现在恺撒拥有了这支曾用来击败他们的舰队，他一定在想：
I could use this. And we know that by 55 BC, he's basically pacified all of Gaul, or so it seems. And he's in a mood to go even further. So his first venture beyond the limits of Gaul is across the Rhine. A couple of German tribes have crossed the Rhine and raided into Gaul. So Caesar builds a bridge, takes him 10 days. He stays in Germany for 18 days. He then comes back and pulls the bridge down.
我可以用这个。我们知道，到公元前55年，他基本上已经平定了整个高卢，或者说看起来是这样。而且他甚至还想进一步深入。因此，他跨越莱茵河，进行了他超越高卢极限的首次探险。有几个日耳曼部落跨过了莱茵河，对高卢进行了袭扰。于是凯撒建造了一座桥，花了10天时间。他在日耳曼呆了18天。然后他回来，把桥拆了。
Spectacular stunt. And it illustrates, firstly, that there's nowhere that the Romans can't go. But more specifically, it illustrates the fact there's nowhere Caesar can't go. Is that really what the invasion of Britain is? It's a coup. It's a spectacular gesture. Does it not also reflect the fact that he knows, he must know or have some inkling that when he went across the Rhine, he's not going to meet an opposing force at the same level of organization and technological sophistication as his own. So it's kind of cost-free, isn't it?
壮观的特技。这首先说明，罗马人无处不可去。但更具体地说，它说明了凯撒无处不可去。入侵英国真的是这样吗？这是一场政变。这是一个壮观的姿态。难道它不也反映了这样一个事实：他知道，他一定知道或者有所预感，当他跨过莱茵河时，他不会遇到一个在组织和技术成熟度上与他自己处于同一水平的对手？所以这基本上没有什么成本，对吧？
I think it's much, much riskier than that, as we'll see, because I think the element of risk is a key part of it. And actually, the French scholar writing about Caesar and Gaul, Christian Goudinot, he explicitly compares it to the moon landings. So he says of Caesar's expedition that, like the moon landings, it's an imagination defying epic, an achievement at once technological and straight out of an adventure story. And so like the moon landings, the drama of it is dependent on risk, dependent on the sense of going into the unknown where things could go horribly wrong.
我认为这比那要危险得多，正如我们将看到的，因为我认为风险因素是其中的一个关键部分。事实上，法国学者克里斯蒂安·古迪诺（Christian Goudinot）在撰写关于凯撒和高卢的文章时，明确地将之与登月进行了比较。因此，他谈到凯撒的远征时说，就像登月一样，这是一部挑战想象力的史诗，是一项兼具技术性和直接源自冒险故事的成就。因此，就像登月一样，它的戏剧性取决于风险，取决于那种进入未知世界、事情可能会变得无比糟糕的感觉。
But a sense, a manageable risk, right? A risk that you think, if things go well, it should be okay. And Caesar, I mean, of course, he could be hit by an arrow or a stone, or he could fall into the sea. But it's not like he's invading Parthia or something, which would be a much bigger ask. I don't know. The anxieties aren't just about the human dimension. There's also the divine dimension. So if you can compare the mission to Britain,
但这种感觉，是一种可控的风险，对吧？你认为如果一切顺利，应该没问题的风险。凯撒，当然，他可能会被一支箭或一块石头击中，或者他可能会掉进海里。但这不像他要入侵帕提亚什么的，那将是一个大得多的难题。我不知道。焦虑并不仅仅关乎人类维度。这里还有神圣维度。因此，如果你能把前往不列颠的任务...
to the moon landings, you can also very obviously compare it to the achievements of the man whose statue in Cadiz inspired Caesar to feel all depressed, Alexander. Because Alexander is said to have pushed to the end of the world and to have reached the ocean, which the Greeks and the Romans believed surrounded the entire world, and to have offered up sacrifice to the ocean there. And Caesar, by crossing the ocean from Gaul, he's doing something very, very similar. For the Greeks, the ocean is divine, and the Romans have inherited that. So there's always the question about, are you divine enough to trust yourself to its waters? So Caesar, by doing that, he's trusting that he will measure up in the divine sphere as well as in the human sphere. Because this is not just the edge of the known world. It's perhaps to some
与登月相比，你显然也可以把它与那个在加的斯（Cadiz）的雕像激发凯撒感到沮丧的人的成就相提并论——亚历山大大帝。因为据说亚历山大曾推进到世界的尽头并到达了海洋，希腊人和罗马人认为这片海洋环绕着整个世界，并在那里的海洋献祭。凯撒通过从高卢跨越大洋，正在做一件非常非常相似的事情。对于希腊人来说，海洋是神圣的，而罗马人继承了这一点。所以总有一个问题：你是否足够神圣，能够将自己托付给它的水域？因此，凯撒通过这样做，他坚信自己不仅在人类领域，而且在神圣领域也能够胜任。因为这不仅仅是已知世界的边缘。也许在某种程度上...
degree the edge of the mortal world. It's kind of a liminal place and who knows what's beyond that mist. Absolutely. And also, of course, the human dimension is also very, very alarming because it's a deeply held Roman conviction. And I think this tends to be true of most imperial powers, that the further you go from the centre, so in the case of Rome, the Mediterranean world, the further you go out, the more barbarous and savage the peoples that you come up against will be. And the Romans have always had a particular dread of the Gauls. So the Gauls had conquered Rome back in 390 BC. Great armies of Germans had descended within living memory of Caesar's lifetime. The man who had married his aunt, a Roman warrior called Marius, had defeated this kind of terrifying
它甚至是凡人世界的边缘。这是一种临界状态，谁知道那团迷雾后面是什么。绝对是这样。而且，当然，人类的维度也让人感到非常非常惊恐，因为这是一个根深蒂固的罗马信念。我认为这对于大多数帝国强权来说往往都是真的：你离中心（以罗马为例，也就是地中海世界）越远，你所遭遇的民族就会越野蛮、越残暴。而且罗马人对高卢人一直有一种特殊的恐惧。高卢人曾在公元前390年征服过罗马。在凯撒有生之年的记忆中，庞大的日耳曼军队曾蜂拥而下。那个娶了他姑妈的罗马勇士马略（Marius），曾击败了这种可怕的...
onslaught of German tribesmen who were absolutely kind of giants. They were said to eat raw flesh. Women were said to be very into genital mutilation, a bit like the Welsh at Pilith. So the sense that the North is an incubator of savages is very, very strongly held by the Romans. And the further North you go, the presumption is, the more terrifying they're going to be. So to go from Gaul to Britain, you are taking an extra level of risk. But that's not just about the prejudice about going further north, is it? Because Caesar believes that there's a kind of economic reason why the people who live on the
日耳曼部落的猛烈进攻，他们简直可以说是巨人。据说他们吃生肉。据说女性非常热衷于生殖器割礼，有点像皮利斯（Pilith）的威尔士人。因此，罗马人强烈地认为北方是野蛮人的孵化器。而且你越往北走，人们就越预设他们会更加可怕。因此，从高卢前往不列颠，你正在承担更高的风险。但这不仅仅是关于走得更远的偏见，对吧？因为凯撒认为，住在...
island of Great Britain will be more fierce. Because doesn't he say in his commentaries that the further you get from the imperial centre, the less likely you are to have been exposed to the Roman goods that make you dissipated and lazy and effeminate and the taint of luxury will not have corrupted the people in Britain? That's a paradox that will run throughout the story, which is that even as the Romans despise the Gauls and even more the Britons for their savagery, at the same time, they kind of admire the savagery as being the expression of a kind of innocence, that they haven't been corrupted by the fruits of civilization. And it's a constant nagging anxiety for the Romans that civilization and empire and greatness
大不列颠岛上的人民会更凶猛，其中有一种经济原因。因为他不是在评论中说过吗：你离帝国中心越远，你就越不可能接触到那些让你变得放荡、懒惰、柔弱的罗马商品，而奢侈品的玷污将不会腐蚀不列颠的人民？这是一个贯穿整个故事的悖论：尽管罗马人鄙视高卢人，甚至更加鄙视不列颠人的野蛮，但与此同时，他们又有点崇拜这种野蛮，认为这是某种纯真的一种表现，即他们还没有被文明的果实所腐蚀。对于罗马人来说，有一种不断萦绕的焦虑，即文明、帝国和伟大...
might be sapping them and making them more vulnerable to the onslaught of these kind of barbarians. That's very familiar. I mean, we're talking about the British Empire. People absolutely thought that in the British Empire. The romance of Africa or of the Northwest frontier was built up with the idea that urban civilization corrupts you and makes you decadent. And the further away you get, the more authentic and the more manly and all that sort of stuff you are. So there's a lot of that going on. There is, but in turn, there's an aspect of
可能会削弱他们，使他们更容易受到这些蛮族猛攻的伤害。这非常熟悉。我的意思是，我们在谈论大英帝国。大英帝国的人们绝对是这么想的。非洲或西北边境的浪漫色彩是由这样一种观念建立起来的：城市文明会腐蚀你，使你变得颓废。你离得越远，你就越真实、越有男子气概，诸如此类。所以这里面有很多这样的东西。确实如此，但反过来，也有一个方面...
American imperialism in that one of the luxury goods that is being exported by Roman merchants is alcohol, and specifically wine. Just as there was a sense in the expansion west in the US that you could use whiskey to kind of sap the moral character of the natives, the Romans are doing exactly the same because they've been introducing wine into Gaul for about a century before Caesar goes to Gaul. The Gauls are taking wine neat. The effect of this is it turns them into lots of alcoholics. People want wine. The only thing they have to pay for wine is slaves. The only way you can get slaves is to fight with your neighbours.
美国帝国主义的体现是，罗马商人出口的奢侈品之一是酒精，特别是葡萄酒。正如美国向西扩张时有一种感觉，即你可以用威士忌来削弱当地人的道德品质一样，罗马人在做着完全相同的事情，因为在凯撒去高卢之前大约一个世纪，他们就已经把葡萄酒引入了高卢。高卢人直接喝纯葡萄酒。这样做的结果是，他们变成了许多酒鬼。人们想要葡萄酒。他们买葡萄酒唯一的支付手段就是奴隶。你获得奴隶的唯一途径就是与邻居战斗。
It serves to foster increased tribal conflict and tension. The Romans can then take the slaves that they're getting for the wine, bring them back to Rome, bring them back to Italy, set them to work in vineyards, growing more wine, exporting it back. So, I mean, unless you're a kind of Gallic slave, it's completely virtuous circle. But the effect of all this for Caesar is that when he turns up in Gaul, they're sozzled, they all hate each other, they're all fighting each other. It's much, much easier to conquer them. He says a people called the Belgae, occupying what is now Belgium. I mean, that's why it's called Belgium. He says that these are the people furthest from Rome and its wine merchants. And so therefore they are the strongest. And the same obviously
它有助于助长不断加剧的部落冲突和紧张局势。罗马人随后可以把他们换取葡萄酒的奴隶带回罗马，带回意大利，让他们在葡萄园里干活，种植更多的葡萄酒并将其出口回去。所以，我的意思是，除非你是一个高卢奴隶，否则这是一个完全良性的循环。但这一切对凯撒的影响是，当他出现在高卢时，他们都喝醉了，他们互相仇恨，他们都在互相厮杀。征服他们要容易得多。他说一个叫做贝尔盖（Belgae）的民族占据了现在比利时的土地。我的意思是，这就是为什么它被称为比利时。他说这些人距离罗马及其葡萄酒商最远。因此他们是最强大的。同样显然...
would apply to Britain. But having said that, there is also a sense that Caesar knows this isn't quite true because he knows that merchants have penetrated into Britain even. There was a little moment earlier on where he talked about the Veneti who control the channel, the exact tolls on people crossing the channel. So people are crossing the channel. So these are merchants, these are even travellers crossing. Well, or there are chieftains in Gaul who have allies or maybe a direct overlordship in Britain, because Caesar in his commentaries is making two contradictory claims. On the one hand, he's saying that nobody in Gaul knows anything about Britain. He repeatedly emphasises this. On the other hand, he says that the Britons are helping the Gauls to fight the Romans,
也适用于不列颠。话虽如此，但也有一种感觉，即凯撒知道这并不完全正确，因为他知道商人甚至已经渗透到了不列颠。前面有一个小片段，他谈到了控制海峡的威尼蒂人（Veneti），以及渡过海峡的人的准确过路费。所以人们正在过海峡。所以这些是商人，甚至还有旅行者在过海峡。好吧，或者高卢有一些酋长，他们在不列颠有盟友，或者可能是不列颠的直接霸主，因为凯撒在他的评论中做出了两个相互矛盾的断言。一方面，他说高卢没有人对不列颠有任何了解。他反复强调这一点。另一方面，他说不列颠人在帮助高卢人与罗马人作战，
and that this is a justification for him to invade Britain. So they can't both be true. Caesar is trying to build up the sense of mystery because the commentaries are being written for his public back in Rome. And so he wants to make it seem as mysterious as possible. He knows that Britain is like Gaul divided into tribes. He knows that there are Gauls who know enough about Britain that they can kind of advise him on what's going on. So I think that Caesar, when he is standing on the channel, looking across at the White Cliffs of Dover, he has a sense that the techniques and methods that he's employed in Gaul to subdue it will probably work in Britain as well. And does he think that he could maybe take interpreters or people who speak the same
而这是他入侵不列颠的借口。所以这两者不可能都是真的。凯撒正试图营造一种神秘感，因为这些评论是写给他在罗马的公众看的。因此，他想让它看起来尽可能神秘。他知道不列颠和高卢一样分为不同的部落。他知道有些高卢人对不列颠有足够的了解，可以就正在发生的事情向他提出建议。因此，我认为当凯撒站在海峡边，眺望多佛的白崖时，他有一种预感，他在高卢征服过程中采用的技术和方法在不列颠可能也会奏效。他是否认为自己可以带上翻译，或者说那些会说相同...
language or a similar language to them, or will understand the British customs and religion and all that stuff? Caesar specifies there's this guy called Commius, who is a king of a people called the Atrebates, which is a Belgic tribe. So again, in the kind of what's Paddy Calais or the Low Countries. And Caesar rates him very highly. He says this man, Commius, the king of the Atrebates, is a man of whose courage, judgment, and loyalty he had a high opinion. Because Caesar, of course, is always speaking in the third person about himself. And Caesar sends Commius ahead of him to negotiate with the various British chieftains there and to try and persuade them to come to terms with the Romans. Now, it has to be said that initially this plan doesn't work out very well, because no sooner has Commius arrived in Britain than he's being imprisoned and loaded down with
语言或与他们类似语言的人，或者能够理解不列颠习俗和宗教等等的人？凯撒特别提到有一个叫科米乌斯（Commius）的人，他是一个叫阿特雷巴特（Atrebates）的部族的国王，这是一个贝尔盖部落。所以同样是在加来海峡（Pas de Calais）或是低地国家。凯撒对他的评价很高。他说这个科米乌斯，阿特雷巴特的国王，是一个他对其勇气、判断力和忠诚度有很高评价的人。因为凯撒当然总是用第三人称来谈论自己。凯撒派科米乌斯走在他前面，去与那里的各个不列颠酋长谈判，并试图劝说他们向罗马人妥协。现在，必须指出的是，最初这个计划进展得并不是很顺利，因为科米乌斯刚一到达不列颠，就被关进监狱并戴上了沉重的...
chains. But Caesar's not worried about this. He carries ahead with his plans. He's got two legions, the seventh and the tenth. The tenth is the guy with the standard-bearer who jumps into the sea. That's about 10,000 legionaries. He's also got cavalry, he's got supply ships bringing food and so on. So probably about 80 ships, most of it drawn from the fleet that he'd used to defeat the Veneti. And early September, he crosses the Channel. And it's one of the descriptions that I always remember from childhood. It was kind of always illustrated in books. He's approaching the White Cliffs of Dover and there are Britons with kind of bristling moustaches. Waving clubs and spears. Yes, brightly painted blue in chariots, kind of racing along the cliffs. And Caesar
脚镣。但凯撒并不担心这一点。他继续推进他的计划。他有两个军团，第七军团和第十军团。第十军团就是那个带着军旗跳进海里的家伙。大约有1万名军团士兵。他还有骑兵，有运送食物等的补给船。所以大概有80艘船，大部分来自他用来击败威尼蒂人的舰队。九月初，他横渡了海峡。这是我从童年起就一直记忆犹新的描述之一。它在书中总是被插图描绘。他正在接近多佛的白崖，那里有留着怒发冲冠胡子的不列颠人。挥舞着棍棒和长矛。是的，身上涂着鲜艳的蓝色，坐在战车上，在悬崖上疾驰。而凯撒...
obviously recognises that this isn't a great place to land. So he passes Dover and he heads up towards the Shingle Beach where Woolmer and Deal stand. This is almost certainly where he lands. It's very, very intimidating for his soldiers. You read out the bit that it takes the standard bearer of the 10th to shame them into climbing out of the boats and wading ashore. The Britons are terrifying because they seem conjured up from all the worst nightmares of the Romans. They have chariots. They're dyed. They have this unspeakable facial affectation.
显然意识到这不是一个好着陆点。所以他过多佛而不入，径直朝沃尔默（Woolmer）和迪尔（Deal）所在的那片卵石滩驶去。这几乎可以肯定是他的登陆地点。这对他的士兵来说非常非常具有威慑力。你读一读第十军团旗手为了羞辱他们，让他们爬出小船涉水上岸的那段话。不列颠人太可怕了，因为他们看起来像是从罗马人最糟糕的噩梦中幻化出来的。他们有战车。他们身上有颜料。他们有这种说不出口的面部怪癖。
Caesar says they shave the whole of their bodies except the head and the upper lip. So that's a moustache that he's describing. Shave their legs, but they have moustaches. It's a concept so abhorrent to the Romans that Latin doesn't have a word for moustache. Weirdly, they don't have archers. They have lots of slingers. If you have a moustache, you don't need an archer. Is that the rule?
凯撒说他们剃光了全身，除了头部和上唇。所以他描述的是那种胡子。刮掉腿上的毛，但留着胡子。这是一个让罗马人如此厌恶的概念，以至于拉丁语中甚至没有一个表示“小胡子”的词。奇怪的是，他们没有弓箭手。他们有很多投石手。如果你留着小胡子，你就不需要弓箭手。是这个规律吗？
That's how it works. How does that work? Your opponents are so terrified that you don't need to even shoot arrows at them. And so, you know, it would be unsettling. It would be alarming. And that is why the standard bearer of the 10th Legion has to do what he does, jump into the sea. Everyone piles out. And should we take a break there? And when we come back, see what happens. In the second half, the Romans land and let us see what happens.
事情就是这样的。这是怎么运作的？你的对手吓得魂不附体，以至于你甚至不需要向他们射箭。所以，你知道，这会让人感到不安。这会让人感到惊慌。这就是为什么第十军团的旗手不得不做他所做的事，跳进海里。所有人蜂拥而出。我们是不是该在那里休息一下？当我们回来时，看看会发生什么。在下半场，罗马人登陆了，让我们看看会发生什么。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The armies of Rome are piling up the beach. They are splashing through the surf. There are flipping javelins or whatever, bits of slings. Slingshot, I think, is the word. When they've run out of slingshot, they're throwing the slings by these terrifying mustachioed figures. This is obviously the moment of maximum danger, any think is the word. When they've run out of slingshot, they're throwing the slings by these terrifying mustachioed figures. This is obviously the moment of maximum danger, any amphibious landing.
欢迎回到《历史至死》（The Rest Is History）。罗马军队正涌上沙滩。他们在浪花中涉水前行。有飞掷的标枪之类的东西，还有投石索的碎片。我想弹丸（slingshot）就是这个词。当他们用完弹丸时，这些可怕的留着小胡子的家伙们正在投掷投石索。这显然是危险到极点的时刻，任何两栖登陆都是如此。
Once that standard bearer has said, come on, follow me, they do manage to get a hold on the beach, don't they? And as I said at the end of the first half, and so it begins. How it actually begins after they've landed is that they build a fort, because there's nothing the Romans enjoy more than building a fort, any opportunity, and they'll do it. So that's what they do. And once they've done that, they then receive emissaries from the local chieftain. And this embassy is led by Commius. So the guy from Belgium they had sent over. Yeah. So he's been freed and he's acting as a kind of middleman. And Caesar tells us in
一旦那个旗手说，来吧，跟着我，他们确实设法在海滩上站稳脚跟了，不是吗？正如我在上半场结束时所说的那样，好戏开场了。在他们登陆之后，实际开始做的事情是他们建造了一座堡垒，因为没有什么比建造堡垒更让罗马人开心的了，只要有机会，他们就会这么做。所以他们就是这么做的。一旦他们做完了这些，他们就会接待来自当地酋长的使者。这个使团由科米乌斯率领。也就是他们派过去的那个比利时人。是的。所以他已经被释放了，并且充当某种中间人。凯撒在...
his commentaries that he reproached them for making war on him without provocation, which I think is- They should have welcomed him with open arms. Yes, exactly. So the Britons duly reflect on their poor behavior, hand over hostages, and it all seems to be going quite well for Caesar. But actually, it's a damp squib. It really doesn't work out well for Caesar, but actually it's a damn squib. It really doesn't work out well for Caesar
他的评论中告诉我们，他指责他们在无端挑起的情况下对发动战争，我认为这是——他们应该张开双臂欢迎他。是的，完全是这样。因此，不列颠人适时地反思了他们糟糕的行为，交出了人质，这一切对凯撒来说似乎进行得相当顺利。但实际上，这只是雷声大雨点小。这对凯撒来说真的很不顺，但实际上，这只是雷声大雨点小。这对凯撒来说真的很不顺
at all. I mean, he disguises this as well as he can in his commentaries, but he's got all kinds of problems. So first of all, he can't land his horse transports, which he's brought over. They keep being kind of blown away. So the very contrary winds and they keep being blown away. And so he's never able to land them. Without cavalry, he can't act on any victory that gets won by his infantry. And the weather just gets worse and worse. I mean, he's kind of arrived in the middle of September. And so as the days pass, the wind seems to have got worse and worse. And there's one particular storm in which he loses most of his transport ships. And this is obviously really, really worrying because you don't want to be stranded on the island and not be able to get back.
一点也不顺利。我的意思是，他在评论中尽可能好地掩饰了这一点，但他遇到了各种各样的问题。首先，他无法卸下他带来的马匹运输船。它们一直被风吹走。所以风向非常逆向，它们一直被吹走。因此他永远无法让它们登陆。没有骑兵，他就无法利用步兵赢得的任何胜利扩大战果。天气变得越来越糟。我的意思是，他差不多是在九月中旬到达的。因此，随着日子的流逝，风似乎变得越来越大。有一场特别的风暴，他失去了大部分运输船。这显然非常非常令人担忧，因为你绝对不想被困在岛上却回不去。
And this terrifies his men. And I imagine probably Caesar himself. It's the first recorded incidence of bad weather in Britain affecting the course of history. This must be the consistently worse weather he's ever known. The rest of his life has been spent in the Mediterranean and Spain and Gaul. You know, I mean, obviously he's known storms before, but this must be the coldest place and wettest place he's ever visited. Yeah. It's very, very unsettling, as is the chariots, which Caesar really, really
这吓坏了他的手下。我想凯撒本人大概也是如此。这是有史以来记录的英国恶劣天气影响历史进程的第一次。这一定是他经历过的持续最恶劣的天气。他的大半生都在地中海、西班牙和高卢度过。你知道，我的意思是，很显然他以前也经历过风暴，但这一定是他去过的最冷、最湿润的地方。是的。这非常非常令人不安，战车也是如此，凯撒对此真的非常非常
obsesses about. It's not just his men who are kind of anxious about. They're only used in Rome for races. The Gauls haven't used them. They're seen as rather old fashioned, but the Britons are very, very adept at using them. It's the chieftains who deploy them. They are very skilled at kind of running up and down the parts of it that connect it to the horses, doing kind of tricks like that, firing their slings, shooting their spears, all that kind of thing. And so generally, I think you get a sense from Caesar that this is actually tougher than he'd anticipated, that the resistance is more intimidating, the weather is more unhelpful. And if you have this kind of shadowy sense that you might be intruding in the dimension of the gods, then bad weather isn't just happenstance. It may
所痴迷的。不仅仅是他的手下对此感到有些焦虑，它们在罗马只用于赛车。高卢人没有使用过它们。它们被视为相当过时，但布立顿人非常、非常擅长使用它们。是首领们部署了它们。他们非常擅长在连接战马的部位跑上跑下，做诸如发射投石索、投掷长矛之类的把戏。因此总的来说，我认为凯撒给人的感觉是，这其实比他预期的要艰难，抵抗更加具有威慑力，天气也更加不帮忙。如果你有这种隐隐的感觉，觉得你可能闯入了神明的领域，那么恶劣天气就不仅仅是巧合。它可能
be expressive of more ominous forces. And so even though Caesar does manage to win another victory, his men are out foraging, they get attacked, Caesar comes to the rescue and beats the enemy off. There's a sense, I think, that Caesar feels like there's nothing much to be gained by staying on for very long. He's made his landing, he's made his point, he can write back to Rome about it. And so after about a fortnight, he takes a chance to go back to Gaul. And that is that. So thinking about, for example, when Hernan Cortes landed in what we now call Mexico. I mean, obviously, the big attraction for him was he was told there's this great city. There's all this gold.
是在表达更加不祥的力量。因此，尽管凯撒确实设法赢得了另一场胜利，但他的手下在出去搜寻食物时遭到袭击，凯撒赶来救援并击退了敌人。我认为有一种感觉，凯撒觉得继续呆下去没有什么好处。他完成了登陆，表明了态度，可以向罗马回信了。因此大约两周后，他抓住机会回到了高卢。事情就是这样。所以回想一下，例如，当年埃尔南·科尔特斯在现在我们称之为墨西哥的地方登陆时。我的意思是，很明显，对他最大的吸引力是有人告诉他有这样一座伟大的城市。那里有那么多的黄金。
There's clearly a central authority in a kind of political structure. Isn't a big problem for Julius Caesar when he lands that there is no central political in Britain, so that he can't pursue a kind of decapitation strategy. He can't say, oh, well, the capital is Birmingham. I will march on Birmingham, seize it and subdue these people. As far as he's concerned, presumably, it's all kind of anarchic chaos and different tribes and things. So what is the point? There'd only be another tribe after the next tribe.
显然有一个中央权威和某种政治结构。对尤利乌斯·凯撒来说，当他登陆时，没有一个中央政治结构，以至于他无法追求某种斩首战略，这难道不是一个大问题吗？他不能说，哦，好吧，首都是伯明翰。我要向伯明翰进军，占领它并征服这些人。在他看来，大概这一切都是无政府状态的混乱，有不同的部落等等。那么意义何在呢？打败一个部落后只会面对另一个部落。
As in Mexico, where there are different peoples and Cortes ends up exploiting that as part of his conquest of Mexico, there is a similar situation in Britain. And if Caesar had landed earlier, if he'd had cavalry, if he'd come in greater force, if the weather had been better, maybe he would have been able to capitalize on that. And I think indisputably, though he doesn't tell us this, but I think it's clear from what happens the following year, he is getting intelligence. He's working out who the various tribes are in Britain, which ones are friendly, which ones are hostile, who might be amenable, who he's going to have to defeat, because Caesar is fully planning to come back the following year. And one of the reasons for that is not just that he thinks that he can beat these people. It's also that the impact of his landing in Britain, even though effectively it's a failure,
正如在墨西哥，那里有不同的人群，科尔特斯最终利用这一点作为他征服墨西哥的一部分，英国也存在类似的情况。如果凯撒早点登陆，如果他有骑兵，如果他以更大的兵力前来，如果天气更好，也许他本可以利用这一点。而且我认为无可争辩的是，尽管他没有告诉我们这一点，但我认为从第二年发生的事情中可以清楚地看出，他正在收集情报。他正在弄清楚英国的各个部落是谁，哪些是友好的，哪些是敌对的，谁可能是好打交道的，谁是他将不得不击败的，因为凯撒正全盘计划第二年卷土重来。其中的原因之一不仅是他认为自己能够击败这些人，
back in Rome is enormous. The Senate, who is full of people who really don't like Caesar at all, they decree him a public Thanksgiving that lasts for 20 days. And Caesar, who is all about making a big splash back in the capital, making himself the darling of the people, he realizes that going to Britain is huge, huge box office. And so I think that that absolutely confirms him in his resolve that he will come back again in 54 BC. So some listeners to this podcast may be thinking imperialism is always driven by the search for markets and resources and things. Is there an economic reason to go for Britain?
还在于他在英国登陆的影响，尽管实际上这是一次失败，但回到罗马后却是巨大的。参议院里到处都是非常不喜欢凯撒的人，他们竟然下令为他举行长达20天的公众感恩节。而凯撒一向热衷于在首都引起轰动，让自己成为人民的宠儿，他意识到去英国是一件超级、超级卖座的事。因此，我认为这绝对坚定了他在公元前54年再次回来的决心。所以这个播客的一些听众可能会认为，帝国主义总是受到对市场、资源和各种事物的追寻的驱动。去攻打英国有什么经济原因吗？
I imagine they're thinking the market of the Britons is crucial to our economic success, but is there a resource? I mean, the classic thing that people always say is tin. They came for tin. Is there any truth in that? Well, the tin is down in Cornwall, so the other end from Kent, but there are all kinds of rumours that there's gold, that there's silver, that there's lead. So the sense that Britain is full of mineral wealth is very strong, And so therefore, hopefully that will be useful. So there are reports that Britain is full of riches. But of course, even if there's nothing there, there is a source of income, which Caesar has been making great use of in Gaul, and that is slaves.
我想他们会认为布立顿人的市场对我们的经济成功至关重要，但有什么资源吗？我的意思是，人们总是说的经典东西是锡。他们是为了锡来的。这有什么道理吗？嗯，锡在康沃尔，也就是肯特郡的另一端，但有各种各样的传言说那里有黄金，有白银，有铅。因此，英国充满矿产财富的感觉非常强烈，所以希望这会有用。因此有报道说英国充满了财富。但当然，即使那里什么都没有，也有一个凯撒在高卢一直很好利用的收入来源，那就是奴隶。
So Caesar in Gaul has enslaved vast numbers of people and become incredibly rich from it. And I'm sure that just on this abortive trip, he's had a number of clashes. He will have taken prisoners. He'll be taking them back with him to Gaul to sell. He is given an opportunity to go back by precisely the kind of factional infighting on the island of Britain that I was talking about, this sense that actually all Caesar has to do is put out feelers to the various chieftains in Britain. As the commander of a large army, he is of great interest to British chieftains who were fighting their own wars, like in Mexico, the Tlaxcala or the Mexica. They see the Spanish as just a kind of interesting addition to the faction fighting that's going on.
因此，凯撒在高卢奴役了大量人口，并因此变得极其富有。我敢肯定，仅仅在这次夭折的旅行中，他已经发生过多次冲突。他肯定抓了俘虏。他会把他们带回高卢去卖。岛上的内讧恰恰为他提供了回去的机会，也就是我刚才说的那个情况，这种感觉实际上凯撒要做的就是向英国的各个首领试探风声。作为一支庞大军队的司令，他对那些正在打自己战争的英国首领非常具有吸引力，就像墨西哥的特拉斯卡拉人或墨西加人一样。他们认为西班牙人只是正在发生的派系斗争中一个有趣的补充。
Even though Caesar's Landing had been very brief, what people had seen of the Romans was menacing enough that some people decide that they want to use it. And in particular, there's a guy called Mandubracius, who is a prince of a tribe called the Trinovantes. And the Trinovantes are based north of the Thames Estuary in what's now Hertfordshire and Essex. They're probably the most powerful tribe in Britain, but there's an up-and-coming tribe to their west called the Catevillani. The Catevillani occupy basically the home counties. They're under a king called Cassivellanus, and he has overthrown Mandibracchius' dad,
尽管凯撒的登陆非常短暂，但人们所看到的罗马人具有足够的威胁性，以至于有些人决定利用它。特别是，有一个叫曼杜布拉库斯（Mandubracius）的人，他是特里诺万特（Trinovantes）部落的一个王子。特里诺万特人的根据地在泰晤士河口以北，也就是现在的赫特福德郡和埃塞克斯郡。他们可能是英国最强大的部落，但在他们西方有一个正在崛起的部落叫卡蒂维劳尼（Catevillani）。卡蒂维劳尼人基本上占据了伦敦周边郡。他们在一位名叫卡西维拉努斯（Cassivellanus）的国王统治之下，他推翻了曼杜布拉库斯的父亲，
the Trinovantian king. And so Mandibracchius has gone running to Caesar saying, please, will you help me? And Caesar goes, absolutely, I will. Of course, I'm all in. And so when he sails back in 54, he does it as the ally of a British prince. And I think you can tell that Caesar sees this as being a genuine opportunity for conquests on a Gallic scale because he comes back with a much larger force. So he'd gone in 55 with two legions. In 54, he lands with five legions. So that's about
特里诺万特的国王。因此，曼杜布拉库斯跑去找凯撒说，求求你，你能帮我吗？凯撒说，当然，我会的。当然，我全力以赴。因此，当他在公元前54年航行回来时，他是作为一个英国王子的盟友回来的。而且我认为你可以看出凯撒认为这是一个在高卢规模上进行征服的真正机会，因为他带着大得多的兵力回来了。所以在公元前55年他带着两个军团前往。在公元前54年，他带着五个军团登陆。所以大约有
20,000 men. He has about 2,000 cavalry. I mean, this is a very, very intimidating force, far larger than any force that a British tribe would be able to oppose him with. And again, he seems to have landed on the beach at Deal or Warmer. The conventional thinking is that he landed on the Isle of Thanet. The Isle of Thanet, nowadays, it's the northeastern most tip of Kent. And there was this channel called the Wonsum Channel, which has been swallowed up. It's now dry land. But back in Roman times, it was a genuine island. And so one school of thought is that Caesar landed there, made his base there. I think it's improbable because Caesar never mentions the fact that he's crossing to and fro from the channel. So I think he probably landed at Deal again or Walmer. And this time he's not opposed because
2,000人。他大约有2000名骑兵。我的意思是，这是一支非常、非常具有威慑力的力量，远大于任何英国部落能够用来对抗他的力量。而且，他似乎再次在迪尔或沃尔默的海滩登陆。传统的看法是他登陆了萨尼特岛。萨尼特岛，现在是肯特郡最东北端的尖端。曾经有一条被称为万森海峡的水道，现在已经被填平了。现在它是旱地了。但在罗马时代，它是一个真正的岛屿。因此，有一种观点认为凯撒在那里登陆，并在那里建立了基地。我认为这不太可能，因为凯撒从未提过他来回穿梭于海峡的事实。所以我认为他可能再次在迪尔或沃尔默登陆。这一次他没有受到抵抗，因为
clearly the force he's bringing is so intimidating that no one wants to stand up to him and so he marches out he storms a hill fort and he's heading westwards when again there's a massive storm and not all his ships have been beached and so he goes back he arranges for the ships to be pulled up and anyone who's been to the beach at deal or warmer will know that it's a perfect spot to drag up a Roman transport ship. And then they build an even larger fortification. So they surround it completely so that the ships are secure from the storms and secure from any natives who may try and attack them. And then he resumes his march westwards again. He goes across Kent and he reaches the Thames. Not only does he have his legions, but he has the Trinovantes and he has five other tribes, he says, all of whom have come to Caesar
很明显，他带来的军队具有如此强大的威慑力，以至于没有人敢与他抗衡，于是他大步向前，攻占了一座山地堡垒，正向西挺进，这时又遭遇了一场大暴风雨，并非他所有的船只都被拉上了海滩，于是他折返回去，安排将船只拉上岸，去过迪尔或沃尔默海滩的人都会知道，那是把罗马运输船拖上岸的绝佳地点。然后他们建造了更大的防御工事。因此，他们将其完全包围，以便船只免受风暴袭击，也免受任何可能试图攻击他们的当地人的袭击。然后他再次恢复向西行进。他穿过肯特郡，到达了泰晤士河。他不仅拥有自己的军团，还有特里诺万特人和其他五个部落，他说，所有这些部落都来到凯撒这里
and have submitted to him. As he's doing that, of course, all the enemies of the Trinovantes, notably the Catephalani, they are also kind of drawing in allies. And so to us, we might see it as a clash between the Romans and the Catephalani, but to the Britons see it as a clash between the Romans and the Catephalorni, but to the Britons it's a clash between the Trinovantes and the Catephalorni, and the Romans are kind of incidental to the story. But of course that's not how Caesar sees it. So Caesar crosses the Thames. We don't quite know how.
并向他投降。当然，在他这样做的同时，特里诺万特人的所有敌人，特别是卡蒂维劳尼人，他们也在拉拢盟友。因此对我们来说，我们可能认为这是罗马人与卡蒂维劳尼人之间的冲突，但对布立顿人来说，这是特里诺万特人与卡蒂维劳尼人之间的冲突，罗马人只是这个故事中的配角。但当然，凯撒并不是这么看的。所以凯撒渡过了泰晤士河。我们不太清楚他是怎么做到的。
He's opposed. There are stakes driven into the river, but he brushes it aside. He storms the stronghold of Catellaunus. So the Romans call it an opidum, which means a kind of fortified town. That's probably to dignify it. It's a bit like Milton Keynes. It's a sprawl of low buildings, doesn't have the feel of a town, of an urban centre. So that gets stormed. There's lots of massacre, lots of enslavement, and Cassivellaunus kind of recognizes that he's beaten. And so he approaches our old friend Commius, the Atrobaton king, the Belgian bloke, to go and see if he can negotiate a surrender. And Caesar agrees terms.
他遇到了抵抗。河里插着木桩，但他不费吹灰之力就将其拨除。他攻占了卡蒂维劳尼人的据点。所以罗马人称之为奥皮杜姆（oppidum），意思是一种坚固的城镇。这大概是为了给它贴金。它有点像米尔顿凯恩斯。它是一片低矮建筑物的蔓延，没有城镇、城市中心的感觉。所以那个地方被攻陷了。有大量的大屠杀，大量的奴役，卡西维拉努斯有点意识到自己战败了。因此，他接触了我们的老朋友阿特雷巴特国王、那个比利时家伙科米乌斯（Commius），去看看他是否能谈判投降。凯撒同意了条款。
Mantabracchius is restored to the throne of the Trinovantes. Cassivellaunus agrees to leave him alone. Both kings hand over hostages to Caesar and agree to pay annual tribute to Rome. And so in late September, he heads back to Gaul. He has lots and lots of prisoners. He has promises of tribute. He has hostages. And above all, he has a story because he can go back and really, really major on the fact that Britain is unbelievably dangerous and savage. So he writes a very detailed ethnographic report about it. He writes women are shared between groups of 10 or 12 men, especially between brothers and between fathers and sons. He says how in the interior of Britain, of course,
曼杜布拉库斯被恢复为特里诺万特人的王位。卡西维拉努斯同意不再打扰他。两位国王都向凯撒交出了人质，并同意向罗马支付年贡。因此，在9月下旬，他率部返回高卢。他有许许多多的俘虏。他有朝贡的承诺。他有人质。最重要的是，他有一个故事，因为他可以回去，并且真正、真正地大肆宣扬英国是不可思议的危险和野蛮。因此，他写了一份非常详细的关于那里的民族志报告。他写道，妇女是由10到12个男人共享的，特别是兄弟之间以及父亲和儿子之间。他说，在英国的内陆地区，当然，
he hasn't reached, though he's relying on hearsay. He says that they drink milk, which is obviously a disgusting habit. They eat only meat. And he describes them as being nomadic, which, of course, they're not. But Romans expect really savage barbarians always to be nomadic. And so that's what Caesar is serving up for them. So those things, this is the first description effectively of life in Britain. So nomadic, meat eating, milk drinking, and they share women between 10 or 12 people, including fathers and sons. Are any elements of this true? I think they do drink milk. I think they do clearly eat a lot of meat. The thing that is really strikingly inaccurate is the nomadic
他还没有到达那里，尽管他是靠道听途说。他说他们喝牛奶，这显然是一个令人作呕的习惯。他们只吃肉。他把他们描述为游牧民族，当然，他们并不是。但罗马人期望真正的野蛮人永远是游牧民族。所以这就是凯撒为他们提供的。因此，这些事情，这实际上是关于英国生活的第一份描述。所以是游牧、吃肉、喝牛奶，并且他们在10到12个人之间共享妇女，包括父亲和儿子。这些元素中有哪一个是真的吗？我认为他们确实喝牛奶。我认为他们显然确实吃了很多肉。真正极其不准确的是游牧
stuff. But Caesar's not particularly interested in accuracy. He wants to give a good story. And again, back in Rome, everyone is completely thrilled by this. So we know this because we have letters by Cicero, the great orator and philosopher and opponent of Caesar's. And so he writes to a friend and he says, the reports back from Britain is that it's more savage than rich, that basically all there are are slaves. So Cicero is absolutely withering about the quality of the slaves. They have no aptitude for literature. They don't know anything about music. Who would ever expect anyone with a knowledge of literature to come from Britain? But this is a kind of amused tone of O'Toole. It doesn't fool anyone. Cicero is as thrilled as everyone else. He also, according to Pliny, brings back pearls. Pliny says that he makes a kind of corslet, a cuirass, out of these British pearls, and he dedicates it to his
这一套。但凯撒对准确性并不特别感兴趣。他想讲一个好故事。同样，回到罗马，每个人都对此感到非常兴奋。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们有伟大的演说家、哲学家、凯撒的反对者西塞罗的信件。因此他写信给一位朋友说，从英国传回的报告说，那里野蛮多于富裕，基本上那里所有的只有奴隶。因此，西塞罗对奴隶的素质极其不屑。他们没有文学方面的才能。他们对音乐一无所知。谁会期望任何有文学知识的人来自英国呢？但这是一种奥图式的 amused 语气。这谁也骗不了。西塞罗和所有人一样兴奋。根据老普林尼的说法，他还带回了珍珠。普林尼说，他用这些英国珍珠制作了一种胸甲、护胸甲，并把它献给了他的
ancestor as Venus in the great temple to Venus that Caesar builds in due course when he gets back to Rome. I mean, I know nothing of pearls. Is there just a finite stock of pearls and Caesar took them all? Or I've never heard someone talking about how brilliant British pearls are. I honestly don't know, Dominic. What I do know is that oysters are a very big thing. British oysters are seen as being the best in the world, equal first with the oysters that you get from the Lucrine Lake in the Bay of Naples. I mean, I think in a way, all this discussion about pearls and oysters and stuff, it's not really the point because the point is the story. It's the opportunity it gives Caesar to play act as Alexander. That's what he's got from it. But having said that, I do also think that all this stuff about treaties and hostages and so on, Caesar is clearly laying
祖先维纳斯，就在凯撒将来回到罗马时建造的伟大的维纳斯神庙里。我的意思是，我对珍珠一无所知。珍珠的存量是有限的，凯撒把它们全拿走了吗？或者我从未听人说过英国珍珠有多么辉煌。老实说我不知道，多米尼克。我所知道的是牡蛎是一件非常大的事情。英国牡蛎被视为世界上最好的，与那不勒斯湾卢克林湖产的牡蛎并列第一。我的意思是，在某种程度上，所有关于珍珠和牡蛎之类的讨论，其实并不是重点，因为重点是这个故事。这是凯撒扮演亚历山大的机会。这就是他从中得到的。话虽如此，我也确实认为所有这些关于条约和人质之类的事情，凯撒显然是在为
the grounds for another visit to Britain where he's planning to do what he'd done in Gaul. He can manufacture an excuse for intervention at any point that he wants. This is exactly the course that he'd been doing in Gaul. This is what had enabled him to conquer the whole vast expanse of Gaul. Or so he thinks. Because in the event, he never goes back to Britain. Because actually, even in the late summer of 54, rumours are coming in from Gaul that the harvest is failing. And over the course of 53, the impact of that and of general Gallic resentments mean that there's a kind of festering sense of insurrection. And in 52, there is a mass revolt in Gaul led by Vercingetorix. So anyone who's read Asterix, Vercingetorix is the guy who
另一次访问英国奠定基础，他计划在那里做他在高卢做过的事。他可以在他想要的任何时候制造干涉的借口。这正是他在高卢一直在做的事情。正是这一点使他能够征服整个辽阔的高卢。他是这么认为的。因为在实际情况中，他再也没有回到英国。因为事实上，即使在公元前54年的夏末，高卢也传来了收成歉收的传言。在公元前53年期间，这一情况以及普遍的高卢怨恨的影响意味着有一种暗流涌动的暴动感。而在公元前52年，在高卢爆发了由维钦托利（Vercingetorix）领导的大规模起义。所以任何读过《阿斯特里克斯》的人都知道，维钦托利就是那个
is shown throwing his armour down on Caesar's feet. It's a kind of parody of a famous picture of Vercingetorix surrendering to Caesar, which he does in due course. But it's a very, very close run thing. And Caesar's efforts are devoted entirely to pacifying Gaul. He just doesn't have time to bother with Britain. And then, of course, in 49 BC, he crosses the Rubicon. The Roman world is engulfed by civil war and people forget about Britain. There's no prospect of the Romans returning there because now what is at stake is what is the future of Rome itself going to be. And then once that is settled, Britain is still too tangential. If you're Augustus or Mark Antony, all the actions in the Mediterranean, all the money or the power or the prestige, I mean, who cares about Britain?
被描绘成把他的盔甲扔在凯撒脚下的人。这是对维钦托利向凯撒投降这一著名画面的模仿，他在适当的时候确实这样做了。但这非常、非常险。凯撒的精力完全投入到了平定高卢上。他根本没有时间去理会英国。然后，当然，在公元前52年，他渡过了卢比肯河。罗马世界被内战吞没，人们把英国抛到了脑后。罗马人重返英国的希望已不复存在，因为现在处于危险之中将是罗马本身的未来会怎样。一旦尘埃落定，英国依然过于边缘化。如果你是屋大维或马克·安东尼，所有的行动都在地中海，所有的金钱、权力或声望都在那里，我的意思是，谁在乎英国？
Right. Whereas the converse, I think, is that for the Britons, the impact of Caesar's invasions are actually considerable. First of all, because even the few weeks that Caesar had been in Britain, the impact of Roman militarism had been highly destructive. For any British chieftain with eyes to see, it had been a warning of just how potent these foreigners across the seas are. Equally, the coming of the Romans to Britain opens up the eyes of people to just how rich Rome is, how wealthy it is, how impressive its material goods are. And so again, that serves to integrate Britain into a Roman world, even if there's not a direct colonization. And the fact that Gaul is occupied by Rome, that Britain isn't, because
对。而相反的情况是，我认为对布立顿人来说，凯撒入侵的影响实际上是相当大的。首先，因为即使凯撒在英国的短短几周内，罗马军国主义的影响也是极具破坏性的。对于任何有眼光的英国首领来说，这都是一个警告，警告这些海外的异国人是多么强大。同样，罗马人来到英国，让人们大开眼界，看到了罗马是多么富裕，多么富有，其物质商品是多么令人印象深刻。因此，同样，这有助于将英国融入罗马世界，即使没有直接的殖民统治。而且事实上，高卢被罗马占领，而英国没有，因为
there are so many links between Britain and Northern Gaul, the Roman occupation of Gaul inevitably has an impact on Britain as well. And you can see this through the afterlife of Commius, the guy who was sent to the British chieftains by Caesar, who plays a very complicated game. And the complexity of the game that he plays, I think is the best highlight that we have into this kind of matrix of relations between Gauls, Britons and Romans. So Commius goes back with Caesar in 54 to Gaul and he assists the Romans against the Gallic rebels there because he's an ally of Rome. But then in 52, when it looks as though the Romans are going to lose and Bersinghetrix is going to win, he switches sides. And he's one of the leaders that leads an enormous force to try and rescue Vercingetorix in Alesia, the fortress where Caesar is besieging him. That expedition
英国与英国北部高卢之间有着如此多的联系，高卢的罗马占领不可避免地也会对英国产生影响。你可以从科米乌斯的后半生中看出这一点，这个被凯撒派去见英国首领的家伙，他玩了一场非常复杂的游戏。我认为他所玩游戏的复杂性是我们深入了解高卢人、布立顿人和罗马人之间这种关系网络的最耀眼的亮点。因此，科米乌斯在公元前54年带着凯撒回到了高卢，并在那里协助罗马人对抗高卢叛军，因为他是罗马的盟友。但在公元前52年，当看起来罗马人要输而维钦托利要赢的时候，他倒戈了。他是领导庞大军队试图在阿莱西亚（Alesia）营救维钦托利的领袖之一，阿莱西亚是凯撒正在围攻他的要塞。那次远征
gets wiped out. Vercingetorix is forced to surrender. Commius retreats, goes into hiding. There are two Roman attempts to try and assassinate him. But then when civil war breaks out, Commius negotiates a deal with Mark Antony, who is Caesar's lieutenant in Gaul, and he gives up hostages. But he demands from Antony that he doesn't have to have dealings with the Romans in person because he's worried that if he does that, the Romans will try and kill him or capture him. So that's agreed. So having done that, while Caesar and Antony are off fighting the civil war in the Mediterranean, Commius moves back to Britain. He sets himself up there as a king in what's now Hampshire. And again, he's ruling a people called the Atrebates. And it's
被全歼了。维钦托利被迫投降。科米乌斯撤退并隐蔽起来。罗马人曾两次试图暗杀他。但当内战爆发时，科米乌斯与凯撒在高卢的副手马克·安东尼达成了协议，他交出了人质。但他要求安东尼不要让他亲自与罗马人打交道，因为他担心如果他这样做，罗马人会试图杀了他或抓捕他。于是这得到了同意。在那之后，当凯撒和安东尼在地中海打内战时，科米乌斯搬回了英国。他在现在是汉普郡的地方将自己立为国王。同样，他统治着一个叫做阿特雷巴特（Atrebates）的民族。而且
unclear quite what's going on there. So there's a tribe called the Atrebates in Belgium. There's a tribe called the Atrebates in Britain. Commius is ruling both of them. Are the Atrebates in Belgium. There's a tribe called the Atrebates in Britain. Commius is ruling both of them. Are the Atrebates in Britain people that Commius has conquered? Are they genuinely, you know, kith and kin? Could be a bit of both, couldn't it though? Don't people make that argument about, for example, the Anglo-Saxons that, you know, identity is not just ethnic. It can be kind of assumed because you are copying the warlord, that kind of thing. I don't know. But what is clear is that as well as the Gallic-British link, there is also a Roman one.
目前还不清楚那里到底发生了什么。所以比利时有一个叫阿特雷巴特的部落。英国有一个叫阿特雷巴特的部落。科米乌斯正在统治着这两个部落。英国的阿特雷巴特人是科米乌斯征服的人吗？他们真的是，你知道的，同胞吗？这可能有点两者兼有，不是吗？人们难道不会对例如盎格鲁-撒克逊人提出这样的论点吗，即认同不仅仅是种族的。它可以被假定，因为你在模仿军阀，诸如此类的事情。我不知道。但显而易见的是，除了高卢-英国的联系之外，还有一个罗马的联系。
Because Commius, even though we have no further references to him in any classical texts after his dealings with Caesar. We do know about him because there is actually a written record, and it's a written record that comes from Britain, and it's stamped on coins that he issues that have his name. And so with this, Britain ceases to be an entirely prehistoric culture. For the first time, we have writing. So is this the very first writing in Britain, Commius's coins? Yeah, probably. Wow. And that's because of the link with Caesar and, because are they in Latin?
因为科米乌斯，尽管在与凯撒打交道后，任何古典文献中都没有对他的进一步提及。我们确实知道他，因为实际上有文字记录，这是一份来自英国的文字记录，它被印在他发行的有他名字的硬币上。因此有了这个，英国不再是一个完全史前文化的社会。我们第一次有了文字。那么，这是英国最早的文字吗，科米乌斯硬币？是的，可能是的。哇。这是因为与凯撒的联系，而且，它们是用拉丁语写的吗？
Yes. So he's picked that up from Gaul, which has been conquered by Caesar, and he's taken that across into Britain and then produced, because they are a marker of prestige and status and kingship, I guess. Yeah. And as we'll see in the next episode, they have a huge influence on other tribes as well. And Britain, as I said, it ceases to be entirely prehistoric and it's reflective of the way in which, I guess, societies on the margins of a great imperial power don't have to be ruled directly by it to come within
是的。所以他是从被凯撒征服的高卢学到了这一点，并将其带到了英国，然后制作出来，因为它们是声望、地位和王权的标志，我猜。是的。正如我们将在下一集里看到的，它们对其他部落也产生了巨大的影响。正如我所说，英国不再完全是史前时期，它反映了这样一种方式，我猜，大帝国边缘的社会不必直接受其统治，就能进入
its orbit, to come within its sphere of influence. So the fact that you're starting to get these coins with names on them in Britain is clearly a marker of Roman influence. But the question for the British tribes is, is that all it's going to be? Is it always going to be a hands-off relationship? Or are the Romans, once they've sorted out their civil wars, which are raging in the decades that follow, once the Romans have sorted that out, are they going to be back? Well, spoiler alert, they are. They are going to be back in the form of the Emperor Claudius and a proper invading army in AD 43.
它的轨道，进入它的势力范围。因此，开始在英国出现这些带有名字的硬币这一事实显然是罗马影响力的一个标志。但对英国部落来说，问题是，这会是全部吗？这会永远是一种不干涉的关系吗？还是说罗马人在解决接下来的几十年里肆虐的内战之后，一旦罗马人解决了这个问题，他们会回来吗？好吧，剧透一下，他们会的。他们将在公元前43年以克劳狄皇帝和一支真正的入侵军队的形式卷土重来。
And if you want to hear that episode right away, you can, of course, do it by joining our own empire at the Rest Is History Club. Rather like the Romans, actually, we rule it with a rod of iron, ruthless, but there are all kinds of extraordinary material benefits. The gifts of civilization. And the prestige and status that come with being a Rest Is History Club member.
如果你想马上收听那一集，你当然可以通过加入我们的“历史就是一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）来做到这一点。实际上，就像罗马人一样，我们用铁腕统治它，无情，但有各种非凡的物质利益。文明的馈赠。以及成为“历史就是一切”俱乐部成员所带来的声望和地位。
So if you're a Rest Is History Club member, you can crack on and listen to it now. If you're not, you can join at therestishistory.com. And if you want to remain on the periphery, covered with woe, drinking milk, and with your moustache and your blue paint, then you can hear the next episode on Thursday. And on that bombshell, Tom, thank you very much. A tremendous tour de force. Goodbye.
因此，如果你是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的成员，你现在就可以继续收听了。如果你不是，你可以在 therestishistory.com 加入。如果你想留在边缘地带，满脸悲伤，喝着牛奶，留着胡子，涂着蓝色的颜料，那么你可以在周四收听下一集。带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，非常感谢你。这是一场极其精彩的杰作。再见。
Allez. you very much a tremendous tour de force goodbye I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
加油。非常感谢你，这是一场极其精彩的杰作，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八盒花边新闻的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开了娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的节目、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。